we are in section eight on the seventh
test we're almost done with this book so
let's start problem number one
problem one
if 6700
is equal to 100
times six k
plus seven
then k equals what so let's divide both
sides of this by a hundred
so you get 100 and you click these two
zeros so you get 67 is equal to six k
plus seven i just divided both sides by
subtract 7 from both sides you get 60 is
equal to 6k
divide both sides by 6 you get 10 is
equal to k
that's choice c
problem 2.
if 3 more than n
is a negative number so n
plus 3 is a negative number that's what
that says right
and if 5 more than n is a positive
number so n plus 5
is greater than 0
which of the following could be the
value of n
so n plus 3 is
negative n plus 5 is greater so
n plus 3 has got to be
greater than or has to be less than
negative 3 right this means that
n is less than negative 3. how did i get
that i subtracted 3 from both sides of
this equation right
and if i if i subtract
5 from both sides of this equation i
would get that
n is greater than negative five so you
have to be greater than negative five
and less than negative three well what's
the only number that i can think of
that's that well there's a lot of
numbers but
a simple one is minus four
right minus 4 is
less than negative 3 right if i draw a
number line this is minus 3
minus 4 minus 5. so minus 4 is less than
negative 3 and it's greater than 9 is 5.
so that's the answer choice b
and you can try it out with minus four
minus four plus three is minus one so
that works minus four plus five is plus
one so that works
problem three
okay and the figure above
okay let me see if i can draw this i'll
draw it big because it looks complicated
a line like that
line like that
line like that they tell us
that this is x
this is y
and then they tell us
let's see in the figure above if x is
equal to 70 so this is equal to 70
and y is equal to 40 so this is equal to
40.
and the dotted lines bisected the angles
with measure x and y degrees what is the
value of z okay so the dotted line so
i'm instead of drawing guidelines i'm
going to draw green lines
so this green line will bisect this
angle so it goes right in between
so if it bisects the angle
what is the measure of this angle right
here
what's going to be half of this angle
that it bisected so this whole thing is
so this is going to be 35 degrees
similarly this other green line is going
to bisect this wide oh
that was using the line tool this other
green line is going to bisect y right
here
right
so it bisects it so if it bisects it
what's this angle going to be
well it's going to be half of angle y
and they tell us angle y is 40. and i
wrote that i referred over it so this
has to be 20 degrees right because it's
half of the full y
and they say what is the value of z well
z is just this whole thing
so it's this angle plus this angle so
it's 55 degrees
and that's choice e
problem four
a piece of fruit is to be chosen at
random from a basket of fruit
the probability that the piece of fruit
chosen will be an apple is two over five
so apple the probability of an apple
probability of an apple is equal to two
over five
which of the following could not be the
number of pieces of fruit in the basket
could not be
so the secret here is
is
you you take two phi two over five and
whatever two over five is times the
number of fruit right two over five
times the number of fruit
has to equal the number of apples
right
and implicitly i mean there's there's
not going to be a there's not going to
be a fractional
number of apples in the basket you can't
pick out a piece of an apple so this is
going to have to be an integer
the number of apples right
so if 202 times 2 over 5 times some
number is going to be an integer then
this number has to be divisible by 5
right makes sense
you know if two-fifths if if there were
ten fruit then this is going to be equal
to four if there are twenty fruit then
this is going to be what what's
two-fifths of twenty it's going to be
eight right but if there were six fruit
if they're six fruit two or if we
thought the number of fruit was six two
over five times six is twelve over five
that means that there are twelve it that
means that they're two and two fifths
apples that's not right so what we have
to find is the number fruit it has to be
some number divisible by five if you
look at the choices they give you 20
that's divisible by 5. 35 is divisible
by 5.
choice c
52 that's not divisible by 5.
and then the other two choices 70 and 80
are divisible by 5. so only c
is not divided by 5 so that's our choice
that could not be the number of fruit in
the basket and you could figure it out
if there were 52 fruit and two-fifths
were apples you'd get a fractional
number of apples and that's not cool
next problem
problem five
a square and an equilateral triangle
have equal perimeters
if the square has lengths of side three
what is the length of one side of the
triangle
so square
and a triangle
have equal perimeters
and square has
has what does it say has sides of length
three so three three
three three so what's this perimeter
it's three plus three plus three plus
three that's twelve perimeter is twelve
well this triangle is also going to have
a perimeter of twelve but it's gonna
have it amongst four sides four equal
side sorry amongst three equal sides
right because there's only three sides
of a triangle
so it's gonna have 12 divided by three
so it's going to have to be four
four and four
so one side of the triangle has length
four
that's choice c
problem 6.
i'll do it here
if x is equal to negative 1 x is equal
to negative 1
and k is greater than 0 k is greater
than 0
which of the following has the greatest
value
okay
so choice a
is 2 times k
times x so k is positive
x is -1 so this is going to be
less than zero so this is going to be a
negative number right
and so we know that that's probably not
going to be the answer
so if we look at all of the choices the
only positive and the only positive
choices are that go are going to be the
ones where i raise
x to an even exponent right because if i
raise x to an odd exponent like let's
see
choice c
choice c is
6 k x cubed
and that's equal to six k times minus
one cubed right because x is minus one
so that's gonna be minus six k
and we know k is a positive number i
mean really you could take you could
just divide you could ignore the k's
really k is just a positive number it's
just kind of a scaling factor and they
all have k in them so you just have to
worry about the coefficients of the x
terms
so one thing we can if x has an odd
exponent on it
it's going to be a negative number so
that's not going to be the greatest
value so there's only 2 that has x with
a so you have 4
k x squared that's choice b
and then you have choice
d
which is 8 k
x to the fourth
well in both of these cases x squared is
equal to one right negative one squared
is one negative one to the fourth is
also equal to one
all right and if k is positive what's
bigger 8k or 4k
well 8k is going to be bigger
as i said they all have k n m so you can
kind of ignore k because it's a positive
number so the answer is choice d
i'll see in the next video